welcome to Jesse Waters prime time
tonight preserving these lands is good
not only for Arizona for the plant
good for the economy the Grand Canyon
uranium mines African coups and Russia
the healing's over me and he's like this
close to my face and he's like what do
you want veterans
disrespected by President Biden
thank you very much now we just
Pamela's electric buses go bankrupt
where's the money plus mushrooms
how many shrooms have you dropped a lot
[Music]
Joe Biden after a 10-day vacation at the
beach returned to Washington and
participated in a ceremony with the
Houston Astros he woke up this morning
in flew to Arizona in prime time
expected him to visit the border and see
the crisis firsthand cartel foot
soldiers with rifles and tactical gear
have just been caught operating on
American soil at our border the influx
is so steady that Biden's border patrol
are keeping migrant families in cages
under the hot desert sun his border app
has been hacked by cartels who turned it
into an international human trafficking
app so we couldn't believe when we
discovered that Joe Biden was traveling
to Arizona
to visit the Grand Canyon
your grand candy wanted the Earth's nine
wonders wonders of the world
literally
think of that I heard you you know it's
amazing and during the symbol of America
for the entire world
America's natural wonders are Central to
our heritage
and our identity as a nation
conserving them not only protects the
likeliers of the people who depend on
them
preserves key pieces of our history
I always thought there were seven
wonders of the world but I don't know
Joe Biden visited the Grand Canyon today
to designate it a National Monument
this would be the 130th National
Monument but as always is the case with
Joe Biden you have to follow the money
when you designate something as a
National Monument you automatically stop
all Industrial and Commercial activity
in the area meaning what Joe Biden's
really doing is blocking mining activity
on a million Acres bordering the Grand
Canyon
what kind of mining uranium mining now
why would Joe Biden block uranium mining
uraniums used for nuclear power plants
nuclear-powered Subs electricity no
emissions
it's also used for radiation treatments
to cure cancer
curing cancer and reducing emissions are
two of Joe Biden's biggest initiatives
so does the United States have enough
uranium stockpiled to just ban uranium
mining from a million Acres
the answer is no
the United States Imports 95 percent of
our uranium
a major energy sector and a national
security sector is almost entirely
dependent on other countries
so who are these other countries that we
depend on uranium Imports
the United States buys most of our
uranium from Russia and Kazakhstan
also Canada and Africa
and Joe Biden is single-handedly losing
Africa
the bite Administration has watched
African allies be toppled by coup after
coup after coup
and fall into Russia's orbit Niger one
of the biggest uranium producers in the
world huge untapped reserves a former
French colony and an American Ally just
fell to a military kill
a month after our secretary of state
visited brought suitcases full of cash
and said everything's fine
and now Russia owns niger's uranium
Russia already supplies 14 percent of
our uranium we pay Russia a billion
dollars a year for it
and their satellites Kazakhstan and
Uzbekistan control our uranium supply
chain so now you add Niger to the mix a
new Russian satellite Russia controls
over 60 percent of the world's uranium
Supply
now Joe Biden is
totally funding Russia's uranium racket
America already sends a billion bucks a
year to a Russian company called racetom
it's the crown jewel of Putin's
industrial base rasatam dominates the
entire European nuclear market so we
send Putin's uranium company a billion
dollars a year which Putin plows into
his War Machine in Ukraine
rossitom's actually been gobbling up
Ukrainian nuke plants one at a time in
the East remember last year when Russia
was reigning lead on a Ukrainian nuke
plant and the Europeans were terrified
it was going to turn into a Chernobyl
Redux
well rasatam also took over the Canadian
uranium company uranium one
remember if that sounds familiar that's
the company that donated Millions to the
Clinton Foundation
when Hillary was Obama's Secretary of
State see the Obama Biden Administration
greased the application for Putin's
racetom takeover of our allies uranium
mines right around the time where Bill
Clinton was paid half a million from a
Russian bank for a Moscow speech
promoting the company
so you have to ask
why Joe Biden who says he's anti-russia
is funding Russia's dangerous uranium
Monopoly that puts America's national
security and energy Independence at risk
why is our secretary of state Anthony
blinken giving razatam exec's visas to
come speak in D.C
why is the only major Russian company
that Biden left off the sanctions list
rosaton
Russia is not only using the billion
dollars to fund the Ukraine war they're
modernizing their own new Arsenal and
pointing more lethal weapons at us
Russia's razzatam's building nuke
reactors in Iran and helping China ramp
up its nuke program
so instead of mining uranium here at
home remember made in America Joe union
jobs Joe no emissions Joe
why wouldn't he starve this dirty
Russian company of cash
it's like Keystone all over again
his entire energy policy favors Russia
and China why is that
well does it have anything to do with
the three and a half million dollars the
Russians paid the bidens
or the Porsche panamerama that the
kazakhstani's gifted Hunter
does it have anything to do with the
three and a half carat diamond that the
Chinese slipped the first Sun
there's something very mysterious going
on in the international uranium Market
that involves the bidens
and the Russians hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else